the first successful Mars mission was in
1964 along the way Mars would become the
space probe Cemetery Bogalusa a lot of
space probes have been lost along the
way some of them we lost track of upon
their arrival others flew past the
planet without stopping and none of
those probes proved useful the first
flyby of the planet was achieved by the
American spacecraft Mariner 4
on November 28th 1964 the space probe
was launched from Cape Canaveral in July
the following year it successfully flew
past Mars and took 21 pictures but
calling them pictures might be a stretch
upon my image the first image came out
in the Jet Propulsion laboratory's the
sequence of numbers form under chief yes
it took a while for the scientists to
convert those numbers into a picture
used to chakras open up they took a big
sheet of paper full of squares and
started coloring in squares with a
pencil in various shades of gravy to
recreate the image so the first picture
we have of the planet is actually a
handmade one almost four years prior to
man's first steps on the moon Mariner 4
was a significant victory after a string
of unsuccessful attempts by both the
Americans and Russians the pictures sent
by Mariner 4 made Mars look like a
barren hostile planet covered in craters
Molly enough kepta Mariner 4 gave us a
wrong impression of the planet because
it showed numerous cratons we figured it
looked like the moon and he much less
alive than we thought it would be only
during the following missions did probes
in orbit send pictures of valleys and
streams of some sort that's how we
discovered how geologically rich this
planet actually was 9 more missions were
launched by the Soviets and the
Americans most failed but in 1971 the
American spacecraft Mariner 9 became the
first to orbit around another planet it
sent back views of the planets dust
storms volcanoes and polar caps